[Music]
Parenthood it's going very well a
terrific show and now you get to work
with Ray Romano
so Ray Romano is on the parrot show
industry love interest on we don't know
yet it's just sort of he's gonna be work
for him and complicated feelings arise
you know I know what you mean yeah and I
love and um but I think everyone goes
through that with Ray Romano yeah he's
really good he's very sexy and funny
yeah very funny guy yeah but when we
work together it's sort of like the two
people in the universe with the like the
lowest self-esteem you and Ray Ray Ray
has so low self-esteem and you have low
self-esteem yeah so like he invited a
couple of people from the show to his
house this past weekend and and this was
literally the invitation here that you
there's a map you you probably can't
come I invited you too late you don't
want to drive all the way out there me I
was like oh thanks but you don't have to
invite me just cuz you invited the other
people you you probably have a lot of
other friends I we probably can't it was
ridiculous it was 40 minutes yeah of him
just inviting you and you saying I'll
never come
and I love that you're Ray Romano
impression is an old Jewish lady